Well if I open my refrigerator I'm going
to pay.
I'm going to hell you and I'm going to
get into Charlotte.
Probably two or three type of either
vegetable or salad or zucchini.
I always have plenty in my refrigerator
along with the beer and and the milk and
probably some cream as well.
So those are angry at the end that are
in the refrigerator and in the pantry.
I have a fair amount of canned and from
canned tuna.
But again there are quality.
You can have extraordinary tuna in cans
from pot to get off somewhere else.
I had no long ago with some apricot in
from Morocco.
They were just fantastic.
You know and so again all beans.
I mean different type of beans.
There is nothing wrong with can beans be
good if I could beans.
I will take beans water and salt and
Velveeta.
That's what I'm going to have in that
can.
There is nothing foreign in that camp
that I wouldn't want to have in terms of
chemical products or whatever.
Liquid.
Or.
TO.
MAKE IT.
IT'S.